[Musik]
zur Urlaubsbeginn erstmal
urlaubsreif Chaos auf deutschen
Flughäfen Wartezeiten von bis zu sieben
Stunden tausende verpasste Flüge
verlorene Koffer
Chaos unter den Wolken
genervte Passagiere
Katastrophe wir haben eigentlich den
Anspruch dass wir als Deutsche sehr
organisiert sind und schauen Sie sich
das an völlig unorganisiert
wahrscheinlich wegen man das
countpersonal gekürzt hat und jetzt kann
man mit den Ansturm nicht mehr
klarkommen es ist eine Schande für
Deutschland und und für unseren ich
verstehe es nicht wir haben in fünf
Minuten Boarding time haben uns jetzt
von der Schlange da hinten bis hier
durchgepfuscht kommen immer noch nicht
rein und ja so das System geht gar nicht
das ist das absolute Chaos
so sah es vor einigen Tagen hinter den
Kulissen des Frankfurter Flughafens aus
dieses Video wurde uns von einem
ehemaligen Mitarbeiter geschickt in
diesem Containern sollen unzählige
kofferlagern alle nicht mit ihren
Besitzern mitgekommen von mehreren
tausend spricht selbst die
Betreiberfirma Fraport
überfüllte Flughäfen genervte Passagiere
Flugverkehr im Sommer 2022 der Grund vor
allem die Arbeitsbedingungen von
Flughafen Beschäftigten die teilweise so
schlecht sind dass die Leute einfach
nicht mehr dort arbeiten wollen oder
krank werden
ein Soziologe hat im Auftrag der linke
die Arbeitsbedingungen in der
Flugbranche untersucht und sagt sie
werden seit Jahren schlechter
die Ursachen liegen ursprünglich
eigentlich in ja politischer
Deregulierung und Liberalisierung seit
den 1990er Jahren die auf der EU Ebene
angestoßen wurden in der Folge ist es
heute ein regelrechter Konkurrenz und
Verdrängungswettbewerb unter den
Anbietern im Luftverkehr in allen
Gewerken der letztlich über
Personalkosten und damit auf dem Rücken
der Beschäftigten ausgetragen wird
vorbei die Zeiten als fliegen noch
schick als aber auch die Arbeit rund ums
Fliegen angesehen und abgesichert war
der Preiskampf der Unternehmen machte
fliegen günstig die Arbeit in der
Branche aber härter diese negativen
Folgen sieht jetzt auch die CDU
es wäre ein Teufelskreis gerade bei den
Airlines zum Beispiel denn die
verbliebenen die auf ihren Schultern
immer mehr Arbeit schultern müssen
entweder werden sie krank oder sie
suchen sich auch andere Arbeit es geht
jetzt darum dass man attraktive Jobs
auch anbietet und auch realistische
Flugzeiten anbietet denn der Frust ist
auch auf Seiten derer die ein Flug
gebucht haben der Verband der
Luftverkehrswirtschaft verteidigt die
Branche und betont dass der Luftverkehr
ein sehr attraktiver Arbeitsplatz sein
in der sehr schwierigen Phase und der
unsicheren Perspektive während der
Pandemie wo geht der Luftverkehr
eigentlich hin kommt er wieder hoch
haben wir doch festgestellt dass eine
ganze Reihe beschäftigte sich
Arbeitsplätze in anderen
Wirtschaftsbereichen gesucht haben
fakt ist die Krankenquote bei den
sogenannten Bodenverkehrsdiensten liegt
zurzeit bei bis zu 30 Prozent gerade
beim Reinigungspersonal sind an manchen
Orten nur noch die Hälfte derer
beschäftigt die vor zehn Jahren geputzt
haben in der Studie äußert sich eine
langjährige Reinigungskraft anonym also
wir sagen immer mit den Arbeitskollegen
wenn wir arbeiten gehen wir gehen in den
Krieg Krieg gegen die Arbeit gegen die
Uhr du musst alles schaffen
da die Leute oft nur für kurze Schichten
eingesetzt werden reicht auch der
Mindestlohn kaum
dieser Arbeit muss eben auch gut
vergütet werden und da haben wir in den
letzten Jahren immer häufiger erlebt wie
Unternehmen tariflucht begehen er
Arbeitsplätze in die Leiharbeit
ausgliedern und so die
Arbeitsbedingungen ganz enorm
verschlechtern die bisherigen
Lösungsvorschläge werden das Problem
höchstens kurzfristig lösen da sind sich
alle Experten einig die Lufthansa hat
schon mal 6000 Flüge allein im Juli und
August gestrichen Urlaubszeit das heißt
auch Staus auf den Autobahnen volle Züge
volle Flughäfen daran sind wir gewöhnt
aber nach zweieinhalb Jahren Corona
sieht das noch ganz anders aus die
Verhältnisse sind teilweise chaotisch
etwa auf den Flughäfen in den letzten
Wochen vor allen Dingen an den
Wochenenden wir sind am Frankfurter
Flughafen und wir sehen hier auch lange
Schlangen manchmal müssen die Passagiere
ein zwei drei Stunden vor den Abflügen
hier sein manchmal sogar noch mehr und
verpassen sogar Flugzeuge ich frag mal
hier schönen guten Tag darf ich sie ganz
kurz wie lange warten Sie jetzt schon
hier
ungefähr eine Stunde 15 hat sie mit der
Fluggesellschaft vorhin noch mal
gesprochen dass sie früher kommen müssen
oder haben sie selber gesagt da kommen
wir lieber früher
viel Glück Dankeschön wer zu Ferien
beginnen in den Urlaub startet weiß dass
er starke Nerven braucht bis zu 200.000
Passagiere werden täglich allein in
Frankfurt erwartet seit dem Morgen gibt
es Warteschlangen und viele hier haben
sorgen dass ihr Flug noch kurzfristig
annuliert wird was schon in den letzten
Tagen zu langen Warteschlangen vor
umbuchungsschaltern führte wie diese
privaten Handyaufnahmen zeigen viele
Passagiere sind vorgewarnt damit rechne
ich schon dass ich später angekommen
werde aber ja ich hoffe einfach dass ich
überhaupt ankommen werde das ist die
Hauptsache die wirklich wichtige Sachen
war also ein paar T-Shirts Hose
Unterwäsche da haben wir untereinander
getauscht damit jeder ein paar Stücke
hat und wenn wirklich alles verloren
geht dann haben wir natürlich richtig
Pech aber
hoffen wir das nicht so passiert
es gibt nach wie vor ein massives
kofferproblem fraport hatte während der
Pandemie 4000 Stellen eingespart und die
fehlen nun was in den letzten Tagen zu
solchen Bildern führte die Koffer zu
spät angekommen die Passagiere sind weg
2000 herrenlose Gepäckstücke Lagen zu
Hochzeiten in den Hallen am Frankfurter
Flughafen die Lufthansa überprüft
täglich die Lage und streicht Flüge
um das System zu stabilisieren um eine
Überlastung auszuschließen aber die gute
Nachricht ist 99% aller ferienflüge
operieren wie geplant und sind davon
nicht betroffen
für die Mitarbeiter der
Passagierabfertigung erleichtert dass
die Lage nicht hohe Krankenstände und
tausende fluganulierungen bleiben vor
allem an ihnen hängen verantwortlich für
das Chaos sei der massive Stellenabbau
gerade in der coronazeit was die vielen
Annullierungen für das verbliebene
Personal bedeuten erzählt uns Christine
die nicht erkannt werden will seit 30
Jahren arbeitet sie in Frankfurt in der
Fluggast Abfertigung aber so schlimm sei
es noch nie gewesen die sind schon
stundenlang in der Schlange gestanden
beim Check-In haben gewartet kommen dann
zum Boarding teilweise und erfahren dann
dort dass ihr Flug spontan gecancelt
wird die sind aggressiv die sind
teilweise übermüdet und wir müssen das
ganze ausbaden
Flughafenchef Schulte hat eingeräumt die
Entwicklung im Lauf der corona-krise
falsch eingeschätzt zu haben die
Probleme am größten deutschen Flughafen
würden wohl noch mehrere Monate andauern
wir sind am größten deutschen
Verkehrsflughafen in Frankfurt aber die
Situation an den Flughäfen in
Deutschland die ist durchaus ähnlich in
dieser Lage ich habe jetzt die Chance
mit Isabel Polders zu sprechen
ja Frau Polders die vertreten ja die
Flughäfen in Deutschland was ist das
Hauptproblem und was verbindet sie im
Augenblick
das Hauptproblem ist dass wir zu wenig
Personal haben und das in drei wichtigen
Bereichen beim Check-In an der
Sicherheitskontrolle und bei den
sogenannten Bodenverkehrsdiensten also
alles das was auf dem Vorfeld
stattfindet jetzt gibt es ja viele
Bereiche an den Flughäfen bei denen es
im Augenblick ganz kräftig knirscht das
betrifft ja nicht nur die
Sicherheitskontrollen das ist ein Teil
das betrifft aber auch andererseits
diejenigen die am Boden beschäftigt sind
von den Fluggesellschaften was kann man
denn jetzt in der augenblicklichen
Situation tun wir sind ja noch in
Urlaubszeiten und diese Urlaubszeiten
werden im Herbst ja wieder beginnen was
ist zu tun
das oberste Ziel von allen ist jetzt
dass sie das fehlende Personal wieder
aufstocken wieder einstellen also es
läuft eine sehr große
rekrutierungsoffensive das eigentlich
deutschlandweit hier muss man halt
natürlich auch sagen dass wir nicht die
einzige Branche sind die Probleme haben
ausreichen Personal wieder einzustellen
das beläuft es ist ja ein leider ein
sehr sehr vielen Bereichen so also wir
haben ja wirklich ein Fachkräftemangel
in Deutschland und ja wir suchen
händeringend wir stellen auch tagtäglich
wieder neue Leute ein so dass es
hoffentlich aber da hängt auch ein
bisschen an an hängt es dann auch wieder
an Corona die Entwicklung ist ja auch
nicht klar vorhersehbar wir wissen alle
nicht was im Winter passiert oder wie
die Zahlen sich im Herbst entwickeln
aber das oberste Ziel ist dass wir jetzt
einfach wieder ausreichend Personal
bereitstellen können
das trotzdem weil sie sagen sie wollen
neues Personal rekrutieren das geschieht
ja auch schon aber den muss man ja auch
gute Konditionen bieten das ist ja nicht
unbedingt der Fall
das würde ich so nicht sagen also ich
glaube dass im Luftverkehr eine
Bezahlung nach Tarif ist der Standard
das ist auch in allen Bereichen so und
der Luftverkehr ist nach wie vor auch
ein interessanter und attraktiver
Arbeitgeber auch deshalb auch weil es
ein spannendes Umfeld ist an einem
Flughafen zu arbeiten die sind heute
schon den ganzen Tag in Frankfurt da ist
immer was los man hat mit vielen
Menschen zu tun und es ist auch sehr
abwechslungsreich und von daher würde
ich sagen dass wir da auf einen sehr
sehr guten Weg sind und blicken auch
positiv auf die kommenden Monate man
kann es den Urlaubern und dem
Geschäftsreisenden nur wünschen ganz
herzlichen Dank
danke schön
Lohndumping schlechte Arbeitsbedingungen
und immer wieder der Versuch die
Mitarbeiter in Subunternehmen
auszulagern das sind so einige der
Möglichkeiten immer weiter an der
lohnschraube zu drehen wie ist die
Situation der Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter in den Flughäfen tatsächlich
wie sind die Situationen hinter den
Kulissen Hannover Airport mitten in der
Ferienzeit ein urlauber-video die
Warteschlange vor der
Sicherheitskontrolle geht fast bis ins
nächste Terminal die Reisenden sind oft
schon viele Stunden vorher da sie haben
sich darauf eingestellt
die Schlange beim Check-In
die Gepäckaufgabe
und dann halt hier jetzt am
für die Sicherheit ja Personal wurde ja
über Corona eingespart und jetzt fehlt
es natürlich an allen denken und in für
uns blöd aber für die eigentlich für die
Leute für die es eigentlich blöd sind
halt die Leute da arbeiten so das ist ja
bei die sind ja total unterbesetzt
das Problem zu wenig Personal bei der
Sicherheitskontrolle die Überprüfung
eine hoheitliche Aufgabe ausgelagert
schon vor Jahren von der Bundespolizei
Securitas ein privates Unternehmen ist
hier am Flughafen Hannover dafür
zuständig wir sind verabredet mit einer
langjährigen Mitarbeiterin des
Dienstleisters sie möchte unerkannt
bleiben die haben uns im Prinzip ins
offene Messer laufen lassen es ist
wirklich so das Personal geht und es
kommt kein neues Personal nach und wir
kriechen auf dem Zahnfleisch aktuell
arbeiten hier rund 320 Mitarbeiter im
Schichtdienst es waren mal gut 450
berichtet die Gewerkschaft Verdi die
Pandemie hat viele in andere Jobs
getrieben die verbliebenen müssen die
Situation ausbaden
ich komme sechs Tage arbeite zehn
Stunden am Stück habe eine
Dreiviertelstunde Pause bzw wenn es neun
Stunden sind habe ich eine halbe Stunde
Pause in der ich nichts schaffe im
Prinzip schlinge ich im Laufen mein Boot
und Wasser runter und wenn ich Pech habe
werde ich draußen vor den Terminals noch
angepöbelt dass ich doch hier nicht zu
suchen hätte und vielleicht eher dafür
sorgen sollte dass die Flüge abgefertigt
werden die Securitas Angestellte
arbeitet seit Jahren am Flughafen 11
Personen besetzen normalerweise eine
kontrollspur berichtet sie durch
Personalknappheit und einen oft hohen
Krankenstand seines an manchen Tagen
aber nur sieben Kollegen ein Mitarbeiter
übernehme dann auf zwei Positionen
dadurch weil natürlich schnell
abgefertigt werden muss haben wir extrem
Druck diese Massen zu bewältigen und das
ist eigentlich gar nicht machbar zwei
Positionen gleichzeitig zu besetzen weil
wir Sicherheit produzieren und ich bin
der Meinung die Sicherheit bleibt
dadurch einfach auf der Strecke und es
ist nicht in Ordnung
wir versuchen zum Unternehmen Securitas
Kontakt aufzunehmen doch vor der Kamera
äußert sich niemand das Statement kommt
schriftlich die meisten Ihrer Fragen
betreffen sicherheitsrelevante Themen zu
denen wir leider keine Angaben machen
können bzw bei denen nur unser Kunde
direkt entscheiden kann was er
beantworten kann und was nicht geht da
es vertraulich oder sicherheitsrelevant
ist der Kunde in diesem Fall die
Bundespolizei lässt den Vorwurf dass bei
den Kontrollen wegen Personalknappheit
möglicherweise die Sicherheit auf der
Strecke bliebe nicht stehen die Teile
ich in keinster Weise
es ist ja bei uns bei der Bundespolizei
so dass wir entsprechend auch
aufsichtskräfte haben das heißt also wir
haben auch hinter den Kontrollstellen
kontroll-beamte die genau das Überwachen
dass wir immer den einheitlichen
kontrollmaßstab einhalten das ist für
uns ein elementarer Baustein sechs Tage
zehn Stunden immer unterschiedliche
Schichtzeiten sind schon gegangen weil
für Familie und Privatleben kaum Zeit
blieb es geht den Kollegen ähnlich weil
man gefühlt einfach nur noch für den
Flughafen da ist und zum Schlafen nach
Hause fährt bei zehn Stunden was bleibt
noch und es geht allen so und alle sind
einfach wirklich am Ende es gibt auch
kein anderes Thema mehr als die
Arbeitsbedingungen an diesem Flughafen
der Traumjob am Airport lange vorbei die
Behörden und der Flughafen versuchen das
angekratzte Image aufzupolieren die
Abläufe seien schon besser heißt es das
Problem sei erkannt und der
Flughafenchef bittet die Reisenden
mitzuhelfen vorbereitet zu sein und
alles wie früher zur Hand haben wie vor
Corona
nur die richtigen Dinge im Handgepäck
und zwei bis zweieinhalb Stunden vor dem
Airport sein mehr ist nicht notwendig
hilft auch nicht dann stehen sie nur am
Ende der Schlange und warten dann zwei
drei vier Stunden bis sie dann beim
Check-In mal dran sind das bringt nichts
ob das hilft feststeht das hohe
Arbeitspensum wird vorerst bleiben
Entspannung frühestens zum Herbst ob
unsere Mitarbeiterin dann noch den
einstigen Traumjob ausübt offen auch sie
überlegt zu wechseln
das ist ja alles wunderbar praktisch man
kann einchecken am Automaten oder auch
das Gepäck einchecken aber was im
Augenblick nötig ist sind Menschen am
Flughafen am Boden zum Beispiel bei der
Abfertigung und die vielen zurzeit die
sind in andere Jobs gewechselt oder es
gibt einfach auch zu wenige die in
diesen Jobs arbeiten und die
Arbeitsbedingungen sind zusätzlich sehr
sehr schwierig deswegen sprechen wir mit
Christoph Niemetz der mir mit Verdi sie
vertreten Verdi streikt bzw sie fragen
sich immer mal wieder was können wir für
Maßnahmen durchführen um die Arbeitgeber
dazu zu bringen die Arbeitsbedingungen
zu verbessern wie ist denn die Situation
im Augenblick Situation im Augenblick
ist derart dass aufgrund des
Personalmangels entsprechen hier die
Abläufe extrem verzögert sind das merken
die Passagiere ja tagtäglich wenn Sie
hier reisen wir sind bereits seit
Monaten an den Unternehmen dran und
haben davor gewarnt dass das Personal
nicht reichen wird für den sowohl für
Ostern als auch für den Sommer wir haben
ein Ostern bereits davor gewarnt dass
das in der Woche als geflogen wurde
schon sehr kritisch war und jetzt der
Sommer der sich über mehrere Wochen
zieht extreme sehr kritische Situation
dass wir gemacht haben bereits im
Dezember auf die Unternehmen zugegangen
gesagt ihr müsst die Arbeitsplätze ja
attraktiver gestalten damit hier wieder
mehr Menschen an den Flughafen kommen in
den Jobs um hier entsprechend das
Personal das Passagier auskommen ja
nicht nur eine Frage des Geldes sondern
der Arbeitsbedingungen auch ja aber
natürlich wenn Personalmangel herrscht
dann haben sie natürlich die Situation
dass sie wenn sie den Flieger abfertigen
mit weniger Kollegen das ist unglaublich
stressig dann werden gleichzeitig noch
Beschäftigte gerade neu eingestellt
glücklicherweise müssen auch noch
eingearbeitet werden und dann haben
zusätzlich zu dem mangeln an Personal
was sowieso kaum leistbar ist die
Flieger hat abzufertigen in der Zeit
entsprechend auch noch die Einarbeitung
es kommt auch die Hitze entsprechend im
Sommer dazu und das sind sehr
schweißtreibende anstrengende
Arbeitsbedingungen
was ist das schief gelaufen ja im Grunde
haben wir jetzt hier die Lohnpolitik der
letzten 20 Jahre die uns auf die Füße
fällt also seit 20 Jahren wird hier
outgesource wird hier ausgegründet aus
den Unternehmen kleinere Unternehmen die
für das große Unternehmen arbeiten genau
aber das sind auch ehemalige Bereiche
beispielsweise der Lufthansa der Fraport
die entsprechend hier in Frankfurt
beispielsweise ausgelagert wurden
natürlich immer mit dem Ziel hier auf
die Tarifverträge zu unterlaufen das
sind nämlich gerade die Tätigkeiten wie
die Luftsicherheit wie dieses B- und
Entladen von Flugzeugen der
Check-in-Bereich wo Menschen gebraucht
werden in der sehr personalintensiven
Tätigkeit und da haben die Unternehmen
über Jahre hin Personal ausgegliedert
und die Löhne gesenkt Traumjob am Himmel
das war einmal die guten Zeiten sind
endgültig vorbei der Kostendruck regiert
auch hier auch das fliegende Personal
muss mit immer schlechteren Bedingungen
kämpfen vertreten werden die Pilotinnen
und Piloten von der Vereinigung Cockpit
und drängt man auf neue Gespräche über
die Arbeitsbedingungen mit den
Arbeitgebern Herr Bayer bereiten Sie
sich auf einen Streik jetzt vor nein wir
sind jetzt in Gesprächen bzw Gespräche
sollen geführt werden da ist natürlich
ein Tarifkonflikt ja der lässt sich aber
möglicherweise über
gesprächsgespräche lösen kann man nur
noch mit Streik die Bedingungen ändern
ein Arbeitgeber würde nie freiwillig
hingehen und sagen komm ich gebe dir mal
mehr Geld ja das können sie ja nur
erreichen wenn Sie eine
Durchsetzungsstärke haben das kann der
Arbeitskampf sein muss es aber nicht der
Arbeitgeber kann natürlich auch auf dem
Verhandlungsweg mit einer Gewerkschaft
eine Lösung finden und das ist natürlich
unser Ziel völlig überrascht vom
Passagieraufkommen Deutschlands
edelfluglinie Lufthansa auch wenn im
Februar die Buchungszahlen schon rasant
steigen trotz mehrfacher Nachfrage
wollte sich Lufthansa weder vor der
Kamera noch schriftlich äußern Anzeichen
von und Planlosigkeit die Politik übt
sich in Schadensbegrenzung mehr hat die
Taskforce Flughäfen nicht im Gepäck drei
Bundesminister verkünden eine Lösung die
aus der Türkei kommen soll etwa 2000
Arbeitskräfte von dort sollen den
Kollaps hier abwenden
die nötigen aufenthalts- und
Arbeitserlaubnisse erteilen wir sehr
schnell dazu hat sich mein Haus schon
bereit erklärt und wir sorgen dafür dass
es kein Lohndumping gibt und auch die
Beschäftigten gut untergebracht werden
ausgeschlossen seine neue Finanzspritze
für die Luftfahrtbranche während der
Pandemie gab es Milliardenhilfen Hilfen
die Jobs eigentlich retten sollten was
nicht geht ist und das sage ich auch
Blick auf den öffentlichen Eindruck das
Unternehmen Probleme schaffen und dem
Staat das sozusagen vor die Tür gekippt
wird letztlich ist es ein
privatwirtschaftliches Problem das nur
durch die Unternehmen gelöst werden kann
ein Unternehmen zeigt wie es anders geht
der Airport Weeze Ferienzeit auch hier
doch von Chaos und langen Schlangen
keine Spur der Regional Airport hat auch
während der corona-zeit auf seine
Mitarbeiter gesetzt und keinen entlassen
das zahlt sich jetzt aus zumeist
Ferienflieger der billig Airline Ryanair
bringen die Urlauber vom Niederrhein zu
zielen in ganz Europa von Edinburgh bis
Barcelona
nach Schlangen ausgefallenen Flügen und
sonstigen Problemen am Flughafen frage
ich jetzt jemanden der hier in einer
sehr relaxten Atmosphäre Flughafen
Direktor ist Herr Papst warum geht das
so entspannt bei ihnen ja nun erstmal
herzlich willkommen Weeze ist ein
Regionalflughafen die bekannt ist und
wir haben ein sehr
enges langjährig anwesendes Team hier
was auch als solches arbeitet also die
Leute identifizieren sich sehr mit dem
Flughafen das ist nicht nur die das
Personal am Flughafen angestellt ist
sondern das betrifft auch
behördendienstleister also unabhängig
von der rechtlichen Gegebenheit der
Firmierung fühlen sich alle als Team und
arbeiten so das ist natürlich in
Zusammenhalt der auch mal das ein oder
andere Problemchen gut überbrücken lässt
und dazu dem hatten wir das Glück in
Corona niemanden entlassen zu müssen und
wir haben auch sonst niemanden wirklich
verloren aus dem Team so dass wir in
Spitzenzeiten gern auch noch den ein
oder anderen zu Unterstützung hätten das
ist ganz klar aber den normalen Betrieb
sehr relaxt und sehr schön für den
Passagier auch darstellen können warum
ist das bei den anderen Flughäfen anders
gewesen da hat man gerade auch bei der
Sicherheitskontrolle den Eindruck da
wird immer sehr stark auf Preisdumping
geguckt also man versucht die
Dienstleister möglichst weit runter zu
drücken in ihren Gehältern
die haben das anders gemacht
also zunächst mal die passagierkontrolle
liegt ja nicht direkt in unserer Hand
wie auch in einer anderen Flughäfen das
ist im Prinzip bei uns gesteuert durch
die Bezirksregierung Düsseldorf und die
beauftragen einen Dienstleister oder
dort wird das ausgeschrieben so dass wir
keine direkten Zugriff dazu haben
letzten Endes ist es glaube ich an den
anderen Flughäfen das ist viel zu sehr
im Detail zu betrachten als ich das
urteilen könnte aber eine größere
Einheit ist natürlich auch schwerer zu
steuern und dass das wir Gefühl ja das
Teamgefühl ist glaube ich bei uns
leichter herzustellen ich kann mir
vorstellen dass das ein Grund sein kann
wir haben Corona erwähnt jetzt wird
überall darauf hingewiesen wir konnten
ja nicht ahnen dass das so schnell
wieder im Luftverkehr losgeht wobei das
ja vor allen Dingen den touristischen
Aspekt anbetrifft haben sie das anders
geplant haben Sie eine andere
Vorstellung von dem gehabt was nach
Corona oder zumindest jetzt im
Augenblick passiert also in die Zukunft
sehen konnten natürlich auch wir nicht
das ist ganz klar wir haben uns
insgesamt die überlegt
wie schnell es zu Ende ist und wie
schnell sich ändert könnten könnten wir
nicht richtig greifen aber dass wir
danach wieder ein Team brauchen und auch
am besten das Team was ich hier mit dem
Flughafen identifiziert das war uns
eindeutig klar und wir haben gesagt so
lange ist irgend möglich ist möchten wir
die Leute haben und auch behalten und
letzten Endes sind wir durch schlechte
Zeiten gemeinsam gegangen und gehen das
jetzt auch durch gute Zeiten wo es
wieder anläuft jetzt gibt der
Flughafenchef in Weeze keinen Rat an die
anderen flughafenchefs in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und darüber hinaus
aber fragen wir mal was lernen wir aus
Corona und was für ja im Grunde genommen
Konsequenzen muss man ziehen also
tatsächlich Ratschläge das würde ich mir
nicht anmaßen das zu geben aber was wir
gemacht haben ist einfach also
miteinander sprechen ja
unternehmensübergreifend
teamübergreifend nach Lösungen zu suchen
und vielleicht auch nicht die zunächst
zuvorderst ins Auge stechende Lösung
jetzt rein kaufmännischer Natur zu
nutzen sondern sagen okay wie lange kann
ich vielleicht einen Plan B verfolgen
der mich aber am langen Ende dann
tatsächlich in der Situation bringt wo
ich Vorteile rausziehen kann und ich
glaube sprechen dass wir Gefühl stärken
das hat bei uns wirklich untergewürgt
[Musik]
fliegen ohne Stress der große Vorteil
von Weeze
entspanntes Reisen in familiärer
Atmosphäre für viele Passagiere einen
Grund ganz bewusst einen kleineren
Flughafen zu werden
which Force your experience
here's here
alles ganz bekloppt ganz voll und hier
es geht gut geht schnell ja ist fertig
das Beispiel Witze am Niederrhein zeigt
kleinere Flughäfen kommen besser aus
dieser corona-krise raus sie sind
leichter zu händeln das heißt das
Management kann sehr schnell zwischen
den verschiedenen Bereichen verhandeln
und natürlich ist die Größenordnung ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt es kommt noch hinzu
dass bei den Regionalflughäfen auch die
Möglichkeit besteht sehr viel schneller
neues Personal zu bekommen und trotzdem
gibt es auch Beispiele an großen
Flughäfen bei denen es wesentlich besser
klappt als an den deutschen großen
Flughäfen wir haben ein Beispiel aus Rom
4 mit Chino
durchschnittlich 5 Minuten an der
sicherheitsabfertigung und der Passagier
ist durch am Flughafen Rom 4 micino kaum
Wartezeiten die Passagiere freuts
okay die Menschen das Essen wir lieben
es und der Flughafen ist super
unkompliziert durchzukommen freundliche
Menschen am Check-In
manchmal gibt es Wartezeiten am Check-In
aber am Ende geht es das ist überhaupt
kein Problem
sie haben viel verändert das ist sehr
gut organisiert sie vermeiden ist die
Leute unnötig aufzuhalten
bereits vor der Pandemie war
Schnelligkeit eine starke am größten
Flughafen in Italiens Hauptstadt
die Wartezeiten an der
Sicherheitskontrolle in Rom betragen wie
sie hier hinter mir sehen können nur
wenige Minuten in 90% der Fälle sind es
10 Minuten im Durchschnitt 5 das
Reisegepäck geben wir nach einem
Interkontinentalflug innerhalb von 40
Minuten zurück
unter anderem deshalb ist Roms Flughafen
bereits mehrfach als Airport Europas
ausgezeichnet ein Erfolgsrezept alle
sicherheitsbeschäftigten sind
Angestellte des Flughafens und arbeiten
nicht über Fremdfirmen und wurden
während der corona-pandemie auch nicht
entlassen das zahlt sich jetzt zu Beginn
der Urlaubssaison Italien aus wir sehen
sehr froh mehr Gäste aus Deutschland zu
bekommen
Verzögerung an anderen Flughäfen wirken
sich selbstverständlich aus aber
insgesamt heben die Passagiere in den
Flugzeugen in Rom in diesem Sommer
deutlich entspannter ab
das bleibt viel rum hier mit Chino zeigt
es geht also doch und man kann nur
hoffen dass die Flughäfen in Deutschland
und alle Beteiligten aus dem gelernt
haben was in den letzten Wochen passiert
ist denn letztendlich wollen die
Touristen gerne in den Urlaub fliegen
und sie wollen nicht vor dem Urlaub
einen unglaublichen Stress am Flughafen
erleben deswegen ist zu hoffen dass die
Beteiligten jetzt miteinander im
Gespräch sind und Lösungen finden
[Musik]